hey let me ask you this um
obviously you're the one guy from
griselda that that that
that eminem didn't necessarily
officially sign
why um what is your relationship like
with m because we all know he has to
regret that decision at this point in
time
um like are you guys cool have you guys
ever had that discussion because like
i never i never even i never like had
that discussion with him
i just met him seen him passing you know
what i'm saying
right with that it's like it's really
not a relationship there the respect is
there you know what i'm saying
you know i mean the [ __ ] he to god but
you know what i mean
to be honest with you as far as me
you know i mean like i i didn't get a
contract oh i did i didn't get a
contract offer from shady until
everybody was offered me so everybody
was trying to come for you that's what i
assumed
yeah yeah you know what i'm saying until
until you know
at a point in time i was like anxious to
sign the shady button but
they by the time they came with a
contract offers like everybody was
coming like signing the deal probably
wasn't the smartest thing for me to do
at that point
at that point in time you could have
probably picked and chose whoever you
wanted to go exactly
exactly yeah you know let me shout out
to shady man i love mike you know i'm
saying me and mike we can't get
uh paul rosenberg always been fair to me
before what i'm saying
always been fair to me so let me ask you
this um
it's crazy what because like you said
um you've turned down some million
dollar millions of dollars in record
deals i'm sure right listen you're
you're and people who don't know this
you've been doing this rap [ __ ] for a
long time
you know what i mean like you're new to
like the the mainstream i guess you
could say
but when it comes to like being in the
industry like y'all have been doing this
forever man so like
you're not gonna jump on a lot of people
jumping on whatever comes their way
you know what i mean they're gonna jump
on some [ __ ] deals you decided to go
with e1 do the label deal
and and i'm assuming ownership has got
to be a big a big part of that but like
what because you say i mean i'm assuming
everybody was trying to sign you
um what made you want to go
the e1 direction and not necessarily you
know
go the direction of a major because i'm
sure
every major was on like trying to tap in
with you
uh everybody asked me that question and
i and the answer is transparency
before i'm saying i don't i can't i
can't be like
label talked all that propaganda none of
that [ __ ] matters to me
the transparency our communication you
know what i'm saying is
who gonna be on these phone calls what
is we doing i can't be i can't be
romanced a couple labels try to romance
me into a contract
of course i want you for what i'm saying
and and let's be real here
a lot of labels just wanted to a couple
labels wanted to take the bsf thing
because
just because of me you for what i'm
saying over at e1
they they concerned about these dudes
and
even at the end of the day at the end of
the day
i could have took it anywhere but i'm
still in these offices
speaking for these [ __ ] so i can't do
what i want to do i got a number these
these are my friends before
you know i'm saying music and you want
to make sure they're good exactly so
it's like e1 it was all good and we had
it was offers on the table and that was
the best one and we was and we were
surprised
i'm not gonna lie we were surprised we
had a great meeting with them
and they followed through on everything
they said and more so the transparency
is the best thing